oh it's easy to see you IMAX and Val or
the party animals is Dancing with the
Stars because when their shirts come off
the party song you're not complaining
are you I won't complain you know what
max might have to tell you down a notch
is reportedly about to become a dad with
his fiancee PETA and I got an exclusive
with the dancin bros before they launch
their own tour
this show is incredibly therapeutic
football it's like family therapy
through dance get ready for the
ukrainian-born Bros to bust out some new
moves and debunk a few myths we're
trying to tell a story of from zero to
dance from the stars some questions get
answered like what are these antics and
why is he speaking so strangely the sec
really arrogant this is a incredible
celebration of dance family ambition you
know it's it's kind of you know our
version of the American Dream but with
Peter and Max making headlines about
their reporting baby on the way it's a
tough time for a road trip you know this
might be the last time we spend this
much time to get to yeah this is a
farewell you know each other door he's
been handed over to miss Pina Murgatroyd
she signed the papers you know it's
official we are getting our divorce
she's definitely gonna come visit she's
gonna be there she's gonna be the song
yeah that's nice uh can we get another
tour book please haha like a bear how
you gonna get a VIN I know the wedding's
not until next year next year are you
guys you guys see pretty much I to eye
on how it's all gonna be like is there
any yeah it's it's it's far I know what
she wants
no I just want I just want her to have
wedding or dreams and and me to also
have the wedding my dreams